Let's see,
Antonio,
what was independence calling for?
Amnesty?
Amnesty is 1 conditional pardon.
Rufián says that they made the pardon.
Antonio,
I understand that we are on the campaign trail,
who have to say these things.
But independence
um asked for amnesty
calls for 1 referendum on self-determination.
They have not had amnesty.
There is not 1 referendum on self-determination.
And there will be.
There will not be. First,
out of personal and political conviction.
Secondly,
because the constitution,
not only the Spanish one.
No constitution in the world
recognizes the right to segregation.
For the same reasons,
on behalf of Spain,
in the interest of Spain,
in defense of coexistence among Spaniards,
I defend amnesty in Catalonia today
for the attractive facts,
there will not be. First,
for personal and political leadership.
Second place,
because the constitution was not only Spanish,
nor the constitution in the world
recognizes the right to segregation